hi everyone my name is Tara chambers and
I'm Cody melts and it is Aaron Jessa and
Cody also just saw two as well
depressingly we just had the emoji movie
we we did do that to ourselves not good
no but I think we have different
opinions on what we got out of this this
is how you know it's a really
complicated artistic piece we have we
have a very we have a very finesse
understanding of how terrible it was I
had to kind of parable where I had fun
with it I thought it was so stupid it
was unoriginal and points very boring
but I knew that going in y'all I knew it
and so I just wanted to have as much fun
as possible and I think I did I think it
was inside I'd like to talk to boss baby
boss baby I'm really sorry man like I
came out swinging thinking you were the
worst thing I was ever going to see
and I I did you wrong man you were
terrible but like you know the enemy of
my enemy is my friend
ha ha ha I thought this was better than
boss baby and cars - for sure cars - I
think it's equally as bad banal poorly
written poorly executed not fought
through green-lighted for no reason etc
etc as cars - I didn't enter such a
place of existential dread as I did in
cart like an emoji movie as I did in
regards to I just like did not like cars
- but I didn't reefing the entire
concept of like human beings being good
people
I knew it was going to be bad I mean as
of this filming it has a three percent
on Rotten Tomatoes
ah a 45 percent audience score which is
not bad
no no but three percent ah that's
amazing it's a movie written by people
who have no concept of things that
they're writing about like this is this
is a bunch of dads who ask they're like
nieces what do you what do you kids do
all day why did they ask their daughters
because they don't have children but no
but they
just dad you don't have to have children
to be a dad I have as much understanding
your fatherhood as they have of anything
involving your phone I'll tell you our
children in any capacity it's a bunch of
guys fine who asks their nieces or a
random girl they saw at a bus stop hey
what are you kids do all day and what's
an emoji you no understanding of phones
like what how phones work like there are
several moments of just that's not how
phones work right also the story is a
story that's so unoriginal it's
something we've seen so many times oh
I'm supposed to be this but I'm not so
it makes me weird but then at the end it
makes me special and I have to go
through all of this self learning and
they go so deep into this unoriginal pit
of darkness and despair that they say
things like I'm just looking out for
number one the whole movie is a series
of advertisement it really is it really
like in your face they jump around at
different apps it's literally a giant
candy crush add a youtube add a Spotify
add a drop box add all adds that's such
an antithetical thing to the concept of
like the original like and there are so
many people try to make beautiful art
out there and they can't get it off the
ground
you got a multi multi theater release oh
I like the voice cast I like to the
vocal acting I thought it was really
nice they had way too good of people on
this divine mystery ding raspberry
Christine actually what was it so weird
Patrick Stewart was the bloop emoji I
feel so betrayed by that I'm sorry
I've lost my will to live the 3d was
completely unnecessary there I forgot
that I was watching 3d until I was
boringly look down at my phone to check
my Twitter and then would be like why is
it blurry oh yeah this movie is supposed
to be in 3d I will say public service
announcement do not use your phone in
theaters unless you're in the emoji
movie when all bets are off there was no
one in the theater that's why we were
used
there were two families there way in
front of us yeah so I wouldn't be using
my photos
yes homage anywhere we're not monsters
the movie is a monster I'm so excited to
see the responses from people like Andre
black nerd comedy and jacksFilms who
have just been like promoting this
out of the stick promoting like
ironically I really can't wait to see
some of these people who have been like
fake excited about the emoji movie to
really see what they think this video is
sponsored by candy crush 90% of the
jokes fell completely flat and not funny
at all but I did I laughing this more
than I laughed in cars too I think I
would rather watch a boring movie that's
not incredibly original to watching
Larry the Cable Guy for two hours and
I'll say on that 90% joke falling flat
that Tamra and I have a 20% plus or
minus difference there
you laughed at one joke I don't think so
said okay fine let me giggle as the
emoticons falling oh okay
yeah the emoticons one was funny he
knocks over a bunch of emoticons because
I hate knocking over the elderly which
was also really I mean I understand
there was no better way to make that
joke but it's such an offer like blatant
statement joke and that's how all the
comedy sells it felt like they were
trying to shoehorn in these like there's
like a bye Felicia Jim right and like
they use a lot of terminals terminology
like sleigh and like a lot of like
finger snapping and very like this is
sassy kid jog and it's like no yeah
those are like those are like the mean
versions of kid talk let's not actually
kid talk and interesting that it's a
movie about emojis which are
storytelling devices and they couldn't
wrap them around a good story I feel
like I mean it's just a terrible concept
for a film but I feel like they could
have done a much better job in putting
into different emojis and making them
more their own characters and like like
the devil was trying to sell time share
to people and it's like I just don't
that's a lot and that doesn't make sense
and I'm not sure where they're going
with that
we're drawing why I did love the spam
folder though she was funny man folder
is still giving you again that was funny
and that was played by Rachael Ray yeah
yeah well Sean Hayes played the devil
yeah pressing yeah this movie went back
in time to a moment in my life where I
was happy and removed that happiness
overcook it took laughter away I mean
what a twist right that I was the Matt
all along you just need a princess to
tell you that she loves you yeah that
wasn't that was my other so I didn't
like this even this is kind of business
boiler day don't be offended because
Jesus yes I just boiled a veggie baby
the movie is about like being an
individual and even like very like
empowering kind of for the princess
emoji but at the end of the day the
movie is about like you can't be
complete without having a partner be
like admits that he's in love with her
and he's like alright let's go live our
life together a loving bliss and she's
like actually I have plan for my life
and I think you should be who you're
going to be but like I had planned I was
going to go do and then he turns into
Matt and the only way to get him out of
being met it's for her to be like
alright fine lesbian love damn and it's
like girl you have a plan it teaches him
that he can't be anything unless he gets
the girl and it teaches her to like
subjugate herself and for the greater
good
settle yeah they're blatantly saying
Hollywood is literally telling everybody
in the audience you have to have a love
interest but if your characters on
screen you as a person cannot be
complete there were also some just weird
moments that were just kind of like well
that were God the part where where she
has an idea and then he the met emoji
finishes to the thought for her and
she's like you know this is always
happening men are always feeling victim
women and then after the next day and it
was a very like oh oh oh okay I mean the
true fair point but also the weirdness
your heart is
situation did not fit in right like the
rest of the steam it's not like it's not
like it was like that happened in like
Wonder Woman or cars 3 which are like
fitness icon films right like true how
the movie was terrible it deserves all
of the badness that's coming towards it
on Rotten Tomatoes I think that I think
that I I had a stupid time with it in a
good way
I hope that this movie gets knocked off
a skiff and falls deep into the jowls of
the Sarlacc
and unlike Boba Fett in what I guess is
not candid anymore is unable to claw
self back up and just dies slowly and
painfully
can we real quick talk about the short
oh there was a short before the movie
and it was like a Hotel Transylvania
short and it was bad y'all it was real
bad and joke is literally a mass murder
is funny and the main vampires like I
need a vacation that's the end of the
short it was not good that's how this
began hahaha I don't know what we're
doing next week maybe the Dark Tower
maybe valerian there's a couple weakness
Dunkirk atomic blondes all to see this
by
[Music]